all right the and and chris's favorite
rule i think we named this after you the
chris sims on side kick no my favorite
rule is the ball that gets fumbled into
the end zone into north korea that's my
favorite
um
do you know do you know once upon a time
and we may have talked about this before
i had forgotten it if i knew about it
there was a time in football early on if
you threw an incomplete pass that landed
in the other team's end zone they got
the ball at the 20. i did not know that
incomplete pass now that's that lands in
the end zone right the other team gets
the ball to 20. that's how that's how
sacred that's how this goes to your
argument that's how sacred the end zone
it is their territory it's the only
thing that's careful yeah but that's
crazy what like what years are we
talking about i really didn't know that
you know me that one is it the twenty
yeah long time like yeah yeah long like
long long right when the forward pass
was just being involved right right okay
marshall goldberg
once yep so the fourth and fifteenth
thing
yeah what do you think do you think he's
got a chance the eagles have once again
proposed my understanding is and and
again this is part of the book research
i was doing because there's a belief
eventually it's going to happen whether
it's this year next year the year after
and this is all driven by the fact that
the current configuration of the onside
kick which has been made far
safer there was a time
20 years ago remember when they you used
to get a mulligan like if you kicked the
first one out of bounds you got to do it
again if you had illegal touching you
got to do it again
they engineered that out of the game
bill cower i'm told was a huge opponent
of that he called the onside kick a
courage drill we've heard chris
collinsworth talk on sunday night
football about how much he hated that
when he was playing that that was car
it was it was a car pile up yes right
all the bodies slamming together
so
so now they've made it safer along with
the normal kickoff return the onside
kick return safer but the problem is
it's not effective so the fourth and 15
play is a way to allow the team that is
behind by more than one score to stay
alive and that's what the league wants
give the team that's trailing by more
than one score a chance to stay in the
game and that's why i think it's
inevitable that it happens yeah i mean i
don't deny that it won't happen i think
we're going that way i mean the onside
kick the numbers are you know so low as
far as in favor of the kicking team
recovering it now there almost is no
chance i don't know if there's any way
they could
you know tweak that to a degree you know
not allow some of those things that we
talked about where you can't send like
four guys out to just crush other people
and then do that could they do that yes
i would love to see that more than the
fourth and fifteen uh maybe i want
fourth and 20 if this is gonna happen
maybe i i don't i i still what i worry
about is fourth and fifteen
in a
no like
like
there's nothing to lose situation
and you got the mahomes and the josh
allen's of the world and one of those
quarterbacks i think that's that's
swayed and a huge advantage to that team
as compared to teams that might not have
that quarterback and are built on
running game and doing stuff like that
and i know what you're going to say and
you're going well you better get a
quarterback i can do it i know i know
you but but that's where i just i i
worry about that rule a little bit
you know i
i this is not something that my brain is
capable of processing in real time but
i'm having like flashes of neurons
telling me
there's a way to do this onside kick
alternative
and make it like the spot and choose
there's some there's some way to make it
there's some way to come up with
something that creates a similar
you pick
something and the other team decides
something you know to i don't know but
the current configuration for the
on-site kick doesn't work they need
something else yeah and i agree with you
fourth and fifteen and then what do you
do you gotta defend the whole field if
you're defending patrick holmes it's not
just the first that's what i mean line
that you're getting to preserve uh
possession you go over the top all the
way to the end and he doesn't care if he
throws an interception or anything so
there's nothing to lose and that's to me
such a great advantage for the offense
in that situation that i do think the
teams with that quarterback
are going to have more success than what
the numbers bear out across the league
and that's going to be a huge what about
this yeah what about this yeah one play
from the five yard line
after the extra point or two point
conversion one play from the five to
determine whether or not you get
possession at your own 25.
one play at the five yard line like
going in if you or what are you and if
you convert it yeah one play from the
five okay after the after the point
after right whether it's one or two
offense stays on the field five yard
line throw the ball into the end zone
run it in whatever if you get over the
line you get to keep possession from
your own 25 or 30 or 35 whatever number
they say and you get it first and ten so
that takes away the aspect of
instead of trying to gain 15 yards
i'm i'm trying to you know i'm going to
throw it over the top and i'm going to
score a touchdown right it makes it
harder to throw that five-yard line is a
hard place to score a touchdown it is
because you know there is the no deep
down listen i i i like where your head's
at there i don't think that's a crazy
idea that's not horrible but i like i
said i really don't i really like that
aspect it's actually not a bad idea i
think what it would i just know this
year watching football
i saw josh allen and patrick mahomes
convert so many third and fifteens and
third and twenties and well i i know
we've said this on sundays where we
almost go
i
you almost expect patrick mahomes to
pick up third and fifteens and josh
allen cause it's just they're gonna buy
time and we know now they're gonna cut
it loose and and do something like that
let alone if there's nothing to lose and
they're gonna lose the game already and
who cares if you throw an interception
that will really sway into if you have
one of those special quarterbacks i mean
they're never gonna be dead and that's
where it could be uh interesting
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports